let me just give you a clue here if
you're reading an article
about investing on the internet
written by someone that calls themself a
journalist
you should stop because to start with
most the people that today call
themselves journalists aren't
they just make up crap and get clicks
okay they're not real journalists there
are some that are real
and let's just pretend though that the
person is a real journalist
which means they went to school
to be a journalist right
not an investment professional right
so you're now taking advice from someone
who got a degree
in english on your investing
who has 125 000 in student loan debt at
the last break we have some people in
the lobby dave
that told me that they read retire
inspired
and took the advice in there and they
retired at age 57
and their everyday millionaires they had
listened they didn't say they didn't
advice they're staring at me right now
i'm looking at them
i'm so proud of them no i really am
because
again wisdom means you talk to people
that have knowledge that you don't have
you work the plan you stay focused on
the plan you make sacrifices
and guess what you get to reach some
goals you get to do some things that you
only dreamed about
and that's the difference between
talking about it or being about it
and i want more people to be about it
and so if you're out there
you need to get started talk to an
investment professional have them review
what you have right now the number one
way people build wealth is slow and
steady
there's no sex appeal to that at all
there's nothing that makes you angry
about that
there's nothing that makes you excited
about that there's nothing that changes
your pulse rate
and so articles that are written to do
that don't get lots of clicks
people that write for clicks write for
drama and they make crap up
and they don't know what they're talking
about in a lot of cases
they pull something out of context and
they move it over there
just to get you pissed off on the
political front
on the racial front on the financial
front
the conspiracy theory front and they
just you know and then they post
something on youtube
and it's all about emotion because
emotion drives clicks and clicks are
where you make your money when you write
in that world
and so the truth or wisdom
neither one enter into the equation
and so just quit reading that crap
no you really do stop it yeah you have
to turn it off just so you're able to
think clearly and understand exactly
what's going on with you
and your future and so again it's just
when discussing your investments your
pulse rate changes
you have a wrong plan yes yes
you have the wrong plan you don't need
to feel fear coming up or
anger coming up or anxiousness coming up
out of your stomach into your heart
towards your throat no you
you don't need that means you have got
done the wrong
thing or you're about to do the wrong
thing
as soon as i get desperate right after i
get desperate 100 of the time i get
stupid
and right after i get stupid i get broke
it has happened to me so many times when
i get
mad or i get desperate and i'm highly
emotional and i make
decisions on that it causes stupidity
followed by
a lighter wallet that that sounds like
that sounds like triplets
desperate stupid and broke it really is
daryl and his other brother daryl you
know that's you know but that
they you you know no i don't know we do
stupid crap
when we are upset yeah we do
when we believe bizarre things
it causes us to engage in bizarre
actions
and bizarre things are what get the
clicks yeah
and so when you read you know i watched
the uh
the tiger woods documentary on hbo
complete hit piece on him
and uh you know i've had so many hit
pieces done on me over the years
that i watch that thing and i go okay i
don't know tiger woods
i don't i could i mean obviously he's
famous
and he's i but i do not know what
happened
i don't really know what happened
in his life in his personal life right
obviously some crap went down right
there's no question about that but i
don't really know
but i know enough about hbo to know that
they didn't tell the whole story right
they had an agenda and then you i
watched another documentary on tiger
last night on the golf channel
and you would have thought he was a
freaking superhero two different people
they're not even the same guy i don't
even know how they where they got to
stand in
two different stories two different
motives
but one is about getting clicks yep
actually both of them clicks yeah yeah
they really are
in both just in two different settings
yep two versions
of what those people think are the truth
and neither one are yeah